Voiceover:We've got some apples here
and we've got some oranges and what
I want to think about
is, what is the ratio,
what is the ratio of apples ...
Of apples, to oranges?
To oranges.
To clarify what we're even talking about,
a ratio is giving us the relationship
between quantities of 2 different things.
So there's a couple of ways that we
can specify this.
We can literally count
the number of apples.
1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6.
So we have 6 apples.
And we can say the ratio is going to be
6 to, 6 to ...
And then how many oranges do we have?
1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7, 8, 9.
It is 6 to 9.
The ratio of apples to oranges is 6 to 9.
And you could use a different notation.
You could also write it this way.
6 to ...
You would still read the
ratio as being 6 to 9.
But we don't have to
just satisfy us with this
because one way to think about ratios,
especially if we're thinking about apples
to oranges, is how many apples do we have
for a certain number of oranges?
When you think about it that way, we can
actually reduce these
numbers, as you might
have already thought about.
Both 6 and 9 are divisible by 3.
So just like we can reduce fractions,
we can also reduce ratios.
So if you divide 6 and 9 both by 3.
6 divided by 3 is 2.
And 9 divided by 3 is 3.
So we could also say that the ratio
of apples to oranges is 2 to 3.
Or if we want to use this notation,
2 to 3.
Now, does that make sense?
Well look.
We divided each of these groups into 3.
So one way to think about it ...
If you divide this whole
total into 3 groups.
So 1 group, 1 group.
2 groups, 2 groups.
And 3 equal groups.
We see that in each of those groups,
for every 2 apples, for every 2 apples,
we have 3 oranges.
For 2 apples we have 3 oranges.
So, once again, the ratio
of apples to oranges.
For every 2 apples we have 3 oranges.
But we could think about
things the other way
around as well.
We could also think about
what is the ratio ...
Ratio, of oranges to apples?
Oranges to apples.
And here we would, essentially, switch
the numbers.
The ratio of oranges to apples.
Notice, up here we said apples to oranges
which is 6 to 9 or 2
to 3 if we reduce them.
And here we're going to say the ratio of
oranges to apples, so
we've swapped these 2.
So we're going to swap the numbers.
Here we have 9 oranges for every 6 apples.
So we could say the ratio
is going to be 9 to 6.
The ratio is 9 to 6.
Or if we want to reduce
it, for every 3 oranges ...
So we're going to divide this by 3.
So for every 3 oranges we are going
to have 2 apples.
We are going to have 2 apples.
So notice, this is just
exactly what we had
up here, but when we had apples to oranges
it was 6 to 9.
6 apples for every 9 oranges.
And now when it's
oranges to apples, we say
it's 9 to 6.
9 oranges for every 6 apples.
Or we could say for
every 3 oranges we have
exactly 2 apples.